hand in hand for peace in the Middle  East for reconciliation between Arabs  and Jews the demonstration in Berlin was  organized by the Peace Initiative salam  Shalom trainee rabbi army Lana is one of  its founders mezlan is his cannon via  sigan now more than ever we want to show  a different picture not just Muslims and  Jews being enemies we want to show there  is an alternative where we are neighbors  and get along well together van zeeland  put me comes from their peace building  work is recognized at the Bellevue  Palace home of German President yo  asking gout gout noticed the group's  efforts to bring religions and cultures  together and invited them to tell him  more their latest project aims to reach  out to new immigrants in Germany they  want to offer support to those suffering  discrimination when they arrive a  practical way to fight anti-semitism and  Islamophobia from both directions